thank you for making me laugh last night
i appreciate it
well i appreciate you taking the time to
watch them film
so one of the things is that you really
never know if you're gonna have
chemistry with people like i've seen
movies where it doesn't happen um but
you the four of you clearly were having
a great time making this movie and it's
abundantly clear on screen uh can you
sort of talk about when you realized oh
this is working
oh well you know rel and i came with
kind of a built-in chemistry because
we've worked together before we're both
stand-ups we've we've been in that world
together
um and meredith and i i believe shared
an agent and so before we shot and she
sent me a dm it was like hey
meredith we're gonna be in this movie
together and it was like oh our agent
just told me about you so you know we
kind of came in with like hey girl hey i
think john was the only one that was
like didn't know what to expect i mean i
i obviously knew who he was and then
when we met he was just so gracious and
so
easy and chill and funny and so it just
kind of organically happened and you
just pray for you pray for casts like
that where you know it just is easy
one of the things that i enjoy about the
film is that it balances
the absolute crazy with like people that
have heart you know it has that that
good line can you sort of talk about
that aspect
oh that was actually what drew me to the
film it was just the the humor in the
heart um especially when i got to the
end of the script and i was like oh
they meant well
okay you can you can find the redemptive
quality in the crazy zany couple that is
ron and kyla and i think that
for me was just like we need more
feel-good
stories we need more laughter for sure
but we need more like oh this is
this is good it makes you feel good on
the inside whatever that like
haagen-dazs ice cream moment is that's
what that was
uh what is it really like filming a
montage where you're going around from
bar to bar
drinking and partying because it's like
a minute of screen time or two minutes
of screen time but it's definitely way
more than a minute or two of filming
yeah uh it's as crazy as you can imagine
it was
full days in puerto rican bars set up
here set up here move here and it was
just like
okay more shots ah okay oh more shots
okay ah you know it's it's it's the zany
and ridiculous and crazy and i think we
also did like the boxing sequence also
in that in that span
so late nights i can't even imagine that
um one of the things that's unique about
this film is that you shot for like two
weeks and then the world completely
shuts down and you have like months to
go before you're filming again what was
that like for you to rap and then be
like are we ever going to finish this
movie
yeah no it was crazy we found out we cuz
you know we were in a bubble almost like
covet was like yeah like in the back
when i was watching the news i think the
nba shut down while we were in puerto
rico and i think that's when little rel
looked up and was like
the nba shut down oh this thing is real
it's like wait what is that you know
like you know the sports has has
completely stopped oh yeah there is a
pandemic on our hands and then we found
that we were shut down while we were in
the air
going from puerto rico back to atlanta
and you know all of us were trying to
like reroute ourselves back home
um and then yeah we didn't pick back up
until september so that first week uh
back on set was just like so what do we
shoot like what what is our motivation
what is this movie
uh we're trying to like figure it out
again but we found our group uh not too
long after
uh i love learning about the behind the
scenes of making movies um besides the
kovid shutdown what else do you think
might like surprise people to learn
about the making of this
oh man um
so we had a first-time director who i
think crushed it
um and you know
one it's it's not easy being a
first-time director it's also not easy
being a first-time director in the
middle of a global pandemic when you
have cast members that you have to like
manage expectations that are you know
afraid and you know meredith had a whole
baby she got pregnant all this so
uh when we were shooting in uh in puerto
rico she was as slim and and and tiny as
can be and then
back in september like she's seven
months pregnant how are you gonna make
this work um and they did you know and
uh it was very interesting so it's a lot
gonna happen in the global pandemic
100 i got to stop there uh i'm just
going to say congrats and i hope it's a
huge hit for you guys
thank you so much i appreciate it